i think now's as good a time as any to
play around a little bit with the
formula for variance and see where it
goes and i think just by by doing this
we'll also get a little bit better
intuition of just manipulating sigma
notation or even what it means so we
learned several times that the formula
for variance
so variance and let's just do variance
of a population it's almost the same
thing as variance of a sample you just
divide by n instead of n minus one
variance of a population is equal to
when you take each of the data points
x
sub i
you subtract from that the mean
you square it and then you take the
average of all of these so you add
the squared distance for each of these
points
from i equals 1 to i is equal to n
and you divide it by n
so let's see what happens if we can
maybe we want to multiply out the square
term and see where it takes us
so let's see and i think it will take us
someplace interesting
so this is the same thing as the sum
as the sum from
i is equal to
to n
of let's see this we just multiply it
out this is the same thing as x
sub i
squared
minus this is your little algebra going
on here so when you square it i mean we
could multiply it out we could write it
x sub i
minus
mu
times x sub i
minus mu so we have x sub i times x sub
i that's x sub i squared
then you have
x sub i times mu times minus mu
and then you have minus u times x sub i
so when you add those two together you
get minus 2
x sub i
mu right because you have it twice x sub
i times mu that's one minus x sub i mu
and then you have another one minus mu x
sub i when you add them together get
minus 2 x sub i mu i know it's confusing
with me saying sub i and all of that but
it's really no different than when you
did you know a minus b squared just the
variables look a little bit more
complicated and then the last term is
minus mu times minus mu which is plus
plus mu
squared
fair enough let me switch colors just to
keep it interesting
let me
let me cordon that off okay so how can
we well the sum of this is the same
thing as the sum of because you think
that we're going to take each x sub i
we're you know for each of the numbers
in our population we're going to perform
this thing and we're going to sum it up
but if you think about it this is the
same thing as if you're not familiar
with segmentation this is a good kind of
thing to know in general just a little
bit of intuition that this is the same
thing as i'll do it here to have space
as the sum
from i
is equal to 1 to n
of the first term
x
sub i
squared
minus
and actually we can bring out the
constant terms
you just can't take you know when you're
summing the only thing that matters is
the thing that has you know the eighth
term so in this case it's x sub i so x
sub 1 x sub 2. so that's the thing that
you have to leave on the right hand side
of the sigma notation and if you if
you've done the calculus playlist
already sigma notation is really it's
kind of like a discrete integral on some
level because in an integral you're
summing up a bunch of things you're
multiplying them times you know dx which
is a really small interval but here
you're just taking a sum and that's what
well i we showed in the calculus
playlist that an integral actually is
kind of this infinite sum of infinitely
small things but i don't want to digress
too much but this was just a long way of
saying that the second the sum from i
equals 1 to n of the second term is the
same thing as minus 2
times mu
is two times
mu
of
the sum
from i is equal to 1 to n
of x sub i
and then finally you have plus
plus
well this is just a constant term right
this is just a constant term so you can
take it out
times
mu squared
times the sum
i sub
from i equals 1 to n
and what's going to be here
what's going it's going to be a 1. right
we just divided a 1. we just divided
this by 1 took it out of the sigma sign
out of the sum and you're just left with
the 1 there
right
and actually we could have just left the
mu squared there but either way let's
just keep simplifying it so this is this
we can't really do well actually we
could well no we don't know what the
x sub i's are so we just have to leave
that the same so that's the sum
oh sorry this is just the numerator
right this whole simplification we just
we're just simplifying the numerator and
later we're just going to divide by n so
that is equal to that divided by n
which is equal to this thing divided by
n i'll divide by n at the end because
it's the numerator that's the confusing
part right we just want to find simplify
this term up here so let's keep doing
this so this is equal to the sum from i
equals
1 to n
of
x sub i
squared
let's see minus
times mu
sorry that mu doesn't look good edit
undo minus 2 times mu
times the sum
from i
is equal to
1 to n
of x
i
and then what is this
what is another way to write this right
essentially we're going to add one to
itself n times right this is kind of
saying just look whatever you have here
just iterate through it n times if you
had an x sub i here you would use the
the first x term then the second x term
when you have a one here this is just
essentially saying add one to itself n
times right which is the same thing as n
so this is going to be plus
plus mu
squared
times
times n
all right
and then
if there's anything else we can do here
remember this was just the numerator so
this looks
fine we add up each of those terms so we
said minus 2 mu
right
from
i equals 1 to oh well think about this
what is
what is this
what is this thing right here
well actually let's bring back
let's bring back that n so this is you
know this simplified to that divided by
n which simplifies to that whole thing
which just simplifies to this whole
thing divided by n
right
which simplifies to this whole thing
divided by n
and which is the same thing as each of
the terms divided by n which is the same
thing as that which is the same thing as
that which is the same thing as that
right
and now well how does this simplify this
is the interesting part
well this nothing much i can do here so
that just becomes
the sum
from i is equal to 1 to n times x sub i
squared divided by
big n
now this is interesting what is
if i take each of the terms in my
population and i add them up and then i
divide it by n what is that this thing
right here
if i sum up all the terms in my
population and divide by the number of
terms there are that's the mean right
that's the mean of my population so this
thing right here is also mu so this
thing
simplifies to what
minus 2
minus 2 times what mu times this whole
thing is mu 2 so times mu squared
right mu times mu this is the mean of
the population so that was a nice
simplification
and then plus
what do you have here
well let's see you have mu you have n
over n those cancel out so you have plus
mu squared so that was a very nice
simplification and then this simplifies
to
can't do much on this side so
the sum
from i
is equal to 1
to n
of x
sub i squared
over
n
and then see we have minus 2 mu squared
plus mu squared well that's the same
thing as
minus
mu
squared
right minus the mean squared
so this already we've kind of come up
with a
a neat way of of writing
the variance
right you can essentially take the
average of the squares of all of the
numbers in your in this case a
population and then subtract from that
the mean of your population the mean
squared of your population so this could
be depending on how you're calculating
thing maybe a slightly faster way of of
calculating the variance so just playing
with a little algebra we got from this
thing where you have to each time take
each of your data points subtract the
mean from it and then squared and of
course before you do anything to
calculate the mean
and you take the square then you sum it
all up then you take the average
essentially when you divide it when you
sum and divide by n we've simplified it
just using a little bit of algebra to
this formula and this is we're getting
to something called the raw score method
we could what we want to do is write
this right here just in terms of x i's
and then we really are what you call the
raw score method which is oftentimes a
faster way of calculating
the variance so let's let's see what is
what is mu equal to what is that the
mean the mean is just equal to the sum
from i is equal to 1 to n
of each of the terms right you just take
the sum of each of the terms and you
divide by the number of terms there are
right
so that is equal to
so if we look at this thing
this thing can be written as
let me draw a line here
the sum
from i is equal to 1 to n
of x sub i
squared
all of that over n
minus mu square well mu is this
so this thing squared so this thing
squared is what
this is
let's see x sub i
take the sum up to n
i is equal to one you're going to take
you're going to square this thing
and then you're going to divide it by we
squared right you divide it by
n squared
and what's this might seem like a more
you know out of all of them this is
actually seems like the simplest so the
simplest formula for me where you
essentially just take
if you know the mean of your population
right you just say okay you know my mean
is whatever and i can just square that
and just put that aside for a second but
first i can just take each of the
numbers square them and then sum them up
and divide by the number of numbers i
have
right i don't know if i wrote no i've
i've erased the last set of numbers but
we could show you that that you'll get
to the same variance so to me this is
almost the simplest formula but this
one's even faster a lot in a lot of ways
because you don't really have to even
calculate the mean ahead of time you can
just say okay for each x i i just
perform this operation and then you know
i divide by n squared or n accordingly
and i'll also get to the variance so you
don't have to do this calculation before
you figure out the whole variance but
anyway i thought it would be instructive
and hopefully give you a little bit more
intuition behind the algebra dealing
with sigma notation if we kind of worked
out these other ways to write variances
and frankly some books will just kind of
say oh yeah you know what the variance
could be written like this or and that
we're talking about the variance of a
population or it could be written like
this or maybe they'll even write it like
this
and it's good to know that you can just
do a little bit of simple a little
simple algebraic manipulate manipulation
and get from one to the other anyway
i've run out of time see you in the next
video